on commence par Benjamin Castaldi et son
jumeau retrouvé à Phuket
c'est énorme c'est incroyable c'est le
gars
c'est le gars après un
atelings qui pour chercher
alors vous avez vu qu'on a fait une
cartographie et tout regardez on a aussi
retrouvé la jumelle de Géraldine maillet
et vous avez une jumelle au Gabon
regardez OK
c'est magnifique c'est
[Applaudissements]
séquence elle est pas là
on a retrouvé également le jumeau de
Jean-Michel maire votre frère jumeau
était aperçu dans le métro de New York
regarder
le jumeau
[Applaudissements]
il a il a écouté il a choisi comme ça
on retourne en Europe avec la jumelle de
Valérie Benaim qui a été vu sur un site
de rencontre Portugal regardez là
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi
contacte des femmes matures
Daniel Moreau
regardez
[Rires]
on l'embrasse Stéphane
j'ai du lourd j'ai du lourd j'ai du
lourd dans le massage ou 7 on a trouvé
le jumeau de Gilles Verdez c'est un vrai
gars
[Applaudissements]
incroyable direction maintenant venez
avec le frère jumeau de Guillaume Genton
regarde mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas cool Kelly on retourne aux
Etats-Unis en Arizona ou la jumelle de
Killy était aperçue sur un plateau télé
regardez oh
ça marche ouais ça marche
elle est un peu plus qu'à réel ça pas de
McCain
on retourne en France direction le Cap
d'Agde ou le jumeau de Raymond a ses
habitudes
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi bien sûr moi aussi j'ai
été chercher
mon jumeau
[Applaudissements]